you are you're a tough guy you're in the
marine for a marine for 23 years yes
okay 23 year marine and you get on the
cover of this magazine it's amazing I've
never seen before but this is the
toughest magazine this is a real
magazine this is a real magazine maybe I
really hope this story ends up with sex
yeah but what does I mean please tell me
this is a real magazine that people can
go out and buy go out and get your
skillset magazine what's happening here
what is this about it pretty
self-explanatory bear play it's a bear
fight a good old-fashioned bear fight
yeah do you talk in the magazine article
about how you would fight bear now I
wish I would have yes no as the bear get
a knife yeah his hands are knives yeah
know that the the owner of the magazine
is a marine and he is a very motivated
it's kind of run by veterans and Sarah
they asked me to be on the cover I was
like of course yeah so I went and played
with them because they they have a real
good sense of humor about everything
right so they know that you're being
kind of funny there yeah he's kind of
into pulp fiction that Pope were yes
yeah yeah fiction quality to I don't
know he's like I just got a picture of
you fighting a bear Riggle yeah what
would you do for real you guy who's been
trained to handle any situation as a
Marine a US Marine toughest fighters in
the world what would you do if you were
you know came upon a bear and you guys
had to have it out what do you do you
know what you're supposed to do if it's
a grizzly bear I lay down and pretend
I'm dead that's
yes that's the one sure that's the right
thing to do is I've heard like everybody
says sure no here's what happens I've
heard if you go up against like a black
bear or one of the smaller of the bear
family but let's say a black bear you're
supposed to get big yeah big possible
noise all this stuff and that generally
will deter if you're going up against a
grizzly bear you there's nothing you can
do you can't outrun it you can't survive
it and chances are it's gonna want to
kill you and eat you so the best thing
to do is pretend you're dead already
because they'll mess with you but then
they may leave you to go look around and
then they'll come back to you when they
leave that's your chance to get away if
they haven't killed you're over it are
you sure because I was told
start kicking at it start kicking just
kicking it yeah and trying to just
irritate it as much as you can just kick
it in irritated like like agitate yeah
agitated and even if it starts to leave
you go after it and I keep slapping it
keep slapping at me like would you call
that a mauling yeah so can I can I ask
ya was it Andy told me and he said yeah
he said I should I should cover my body
in baked obits yeah please don't with
them personal security Andy wants me to
get killed real fast yeah
you